[Music]
where did the names of the months come
from
they come like so many things from the
romans
before the norman conquest of england in
1066 the anglo-saxons had their own
names for the months but the latin names
became more and more used throughout
europe during the high middle ages
eventually they supplanted the native
names in places like france germany and
england okay so we have to go back to
rome the original roman calendar had
only 10 months consisting of 304 days
the two missing months were in winter
which was a monthless part of the year
and so the original calendar started in
march and that's where we'll start this
will be helpful as we go along trust me
before we continue here's a quick word
from our sponsor and that sponsor is
babel have you ever wanted to learn a
new language or maybe brush up on one
that you learned in high school or
college but you just don't know where to
start
well then let me introduce you to babel
babel is the premier language learning
app on the market it teaches real world
practical conversations and easy to
digest 10 minute lessons i'm using it to
brush up on the french i learned in
college bonjour jesui le pepe geneliste
pebel
how was my accent need some work well
that's no problem
because babel uses speech recognition
software to help improve your
pronunciation and accent i know my
viewers are always looking to learn new
things so whether you're traveling to
new lands trying to connect with
non-english speakers in your community
or just want to improve yourself why not
give babble a try click the link in the
description to get 65 off your first
purchase thank you again to babel and
now back to the video
so march or martius in the original
latin was named for mars the roman god
of war
mars was equivalent to ares in greece
if you know about greek paganism he
wasn't very respected in greece seen as
a god of bloodshed and violence in rome
though he was much more revered seen as
one of the most important of the twelve
olympians the romans associated mars
with strategy and intelligence rather
than bloodshed and was believed to have
been the father of romulus and remus the
legendary founders of the city of rome
april or aprilis is our first month with
uncertain etymology
it could be named for aphrodite the
greek goddess of love and beauty
the romans called her venus which seems
to cast some doubt on this explanation
but she was called a prue by the
etruscans so maybe that explains it
the other explanation is that april is
connected with the latin verb aperi re
which means to open this could refer to
the opening or beginning of spring
or to the opening or blooming of flowers
quick side note the anglo-saxon name for
this month was eastermonith named for
the goddess wester
she was a fertility goddess in the
germanic pantheon of gods this is where
we get our word for the christian
holiday easter
the month of may also has an uncertain
etymology but it's mostly agreed that it
was named for the goddess maya maya was
a minor goddess in roman paganism but
she was the mother of a very important
god mercury mercury was the herald of
the gods and the deity associated with
travelers merchants messengers and
thieves he was also associated with may
so that lends credence to this theory
there is another explanation though this
one given to us by ovid one of the most
celebrated roman poets
he thought that the month was named for
the mayors which in latin meant elders
so may was for the elder citizens of
rome while june was for the youth or in
latin juniores
speaking of let's move on to june as i
said ovid thought the month was named
for the young people of rome but most
scholars disagree instead it's believed
that june was named for juno the goddess
of motherhood and child rearing she was
the queen of the olympians and wife to
jupiter
this to me seems a more likely
explanation than ovid's theory now
moving on to july and august these two
months were renamed at the start of the
imperial period of roman history to
honor and deify two roman emperors
julius caesar and caesar augustus and
yes i know julius caesar wasn't
technically emperor he held the title
dictator but same difference so july
named for julius used to be named
quintillus which meant fifth month
remember we're counting for march as
month one and august was named for
augustus the first true emperor of rome
it had the name sextilus meaning sixth
month thank goodness it was renamed or
we would have another uranus on our
hands there's a common myth about august
that you may have heard the story goes
like this augustus wanted to be seen as
equal or greater to his uncle julius
caesar so he made it so that his month
had 31 days the same as july he did this
by taking a day from february and giving
it to august and thus messing up the
nice alternating system of 30 and 31
dayed months
this myth is not true
or at least there's no evidence to
support it august did at one point have
only 30 days but the number of days in
each month changed a number of times
throughout roman history and it seems
like sextillis already had 31 days by
the time it was renamed so no you can't
blame augustus for making you forget how
many days are in each month the next
four months are unremarkable they're
named for numbers september meaning
seventh month october meaning 8th
november 9th and december the 10th and
last month of the original system
last two months were added in the 8th
century bc by numa pompilius the second
king of rome
january was named for the many headed
god giannis he was the god of
transitions and doorways which is
fitting for the new first month of the
year
interestingly he was a specifically
italian god having no greek equivalent
and finally we have february it is the
only month not named for a god or number
at least if you discount ovid's theories
about may and june
february was named for a festival that
occurred in its days called februa it
was a roman purification festival held
in and around the lupercull cave where
it was believed romulus and remus were
nursed to health by a she-wolf the
festival was also called lupercalia for
this reason
so there you are the origins of the
names of the months
hope you enjoyed
again i'd like to thank babel for
sponsoring this video and thank you to
my patrons if you want to support the
channel directly please consider
supporting said patreon the link is in
the description if not please like and
subscribe
bye
[Music]